>> Harnarayan: GAME SEVEN
OFFICIALLY UNDERWAYAYAKING
HIS FIRST SAVE OF THIS GAMESEVE.
THEY'D LIKE TO WRITE GAME
SIX.
EDLER PUTS ONE TO NET!
JUST MISSEDDY IMPORTANT IN
THIS GAME.
THEY FOUND MORE
NOW HE DOES.
AND NOW IT'S ARCHIBALD WHO TAKES
A HIT.
A LOT OF
EMOTION SCORING AFTER THE BIRTH
OF A CHILD. YOU WERE TALKING WIH
ME DURING THE INTERMISSION HOW
IN THE
SERIES.
DRAISAITL HAS OFF.
TYSON BARRIE WAS ABLE TO PREVENT
THAT FROM HAPPENING.
HIM FROM THE DISTANCE.
SHOT HAPPY ONCE AGAIN.
AND LEON DRAISAITL
OUT TO TAKE A FACE OFF AND W
YAMAMOTO ON HYMAN WITH HIM.
HYMAN TAKES  FOREHAND.
AND KANE GETS A PRETTY GOOD CHOP
AT THE PUCK AND IT'S GOINGVID.
HE'S ON THE PROWL.
CECI SHOOOOCE IN THE SECOND PER,
CREATING T THE POINT, BARRIE, T
OFF.
STRONG MOVE BY HYMAN DOWN LOW AS
PRESSURE ON IN THE POWER PLAY.
YAMAMOTO WAS LOOKING FOR
ANYTHING.
THE LOS ANGELES KINGS.
THEY'VE BEEN EXCELLENT DIVING I.
OFFENSIVE ZONE FACE OFF AGAIN A
THE ANAN WAY
THERE.
RUSSELL, WHO KASSIAN
EITHERER BACK O IN THE
NATIONAL HOCKEY LEAGUE CHANGING
IN DIRECTION.
FIRES ON YAMAMOTO.
A PE HIT.
SMITH!RYING TO
AS TIME WINDS DOWN HERE IN
THE KINGS.
FIRST ROUND PLAYOFF MATCH-UP
HERE IN THE OFFENSIVE
ZONE.
THEY DON'T PERIOD.
BOTH TEAMS ARE GIVING IT THEIR
ALL.
THAT SECOND
PUCK WAS.ICH THEY DOMINATED.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> Harnarayan: OILERS IPHILLIP .
TO and Applause ]THE PUCK ONTOL
YAMAMOTO.
TRYING TO FIND MCDAVID!
HE DOES!
GOING TO THE NET!
IT'S A PENALTY DELAYED TO